[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRANT TIMMERMAN: So my
name's Grant Timmerman.
I'm a developer , platform
engineer in Google Cloud
Platform.
Previously, I led open
source for G Suite APIs.
And in particular,
I love Node, GitHub.
And I play the alto
sax in my spare time.
So the proposed agenda
for today is, first,
what is functions as a service?
What is the difference between
functions and microservices
running Google Cloud functions?
And then this new thing,
the Functions framework--
you might have heard of it.
It's an open source
platform that powers Google
Cloud Functions for Node.
And then a couple
of quick demos.
So first, when you're
thinking about serverless,
we're talking about
Google Cloud Functions
and being able to develop
functions on-the-fly.
So what is functions
as a service?
Well, so functions as a service
is on-demand infrastructure
for executing your code.
As Kevin said, it's
where you can just solely
focus on your
application, rather
than having to worry about the
infrastructure that powers it.
So traditionally, you
have servers where you
have to maintain your hardware.
You have maintenance,
spare parts.
You have staff, DevOps.
You have server rooms.
You have to worry about
electricity cooling.
And you might have some idle
time with these servers.
And you might have
to patch your servers
and patch your hardware.
And you also have
to overprovision,
if you have traffic spikes,
in case it's Black Friday
or you need to make sure
that your load is kept.
And so this can cost a
lot of money and cost
a lot of time, something
that you don't want to do.
Well, so why do we really
think about servers?
And why can't we just focus
on our core application,
what we're good at?
Why can't we let Google
do the hard part?
Well, so that's where our
functions as a service
comes in.
So it's part of the
serverless movement.
And it's where your logic is
written by the application
developer, runs in a managed
stateless computing container,
and you have special triggers,
like HTTP, Pub/Sub topics,
or dual cloud storage
upload that is
able to trigger your function.
It's ephemeral.
So that means your
function invocation,
it won't have global state.
And it's also managed
by a third party.
So serverless--
Google Cloud Functions
is a serverless environment
to build and connect services
with code.
Basically, an event is emitted,
a function is triggered,
and your code is executed.
You can trigger HTTP functions
from all sorts of environments,
also from Drive,
Calendar, Gmail, and Maps.
Or you can have your
background functions
trigger from Google Cloud
Storage, Stackdriver, Cloud
Pub/Sub, Firebase, et cetera.
Fourth is that it's managed.
So your cloud function might be
running in one of Google's data
centers, one of these racks.
You don't really need to worry
about where it's being run.
So Deep Kapadia stated
that Google Cloud Functions
is really useful for
"The New York Times."
So "Google Cloud
serverless platform
allows us to focus on building
product features without having
to worry about
provisioning, scaling,
and configuration management for
the underlying infrastructure.
The tools and abstractions
have been a game changer,
allowing teams to iterate
and scale with ease."
Now onto, what's the
difference between monoliths
and microservices?
Well, so traditionally
with a monolith,
you have a single application.
It's one giant app.
You deploy it all at once.
And fundamentally, there's
different pieces of logic.
You might have a couple
databases, a couple application
pieces of logic.
And the idea of microservices
is to really break away
this monolithic application and
configure your points of entry,
which might be anything from
Google Cloud storage uploads,
HTTP triggers, Pub/Sub events,
and be able to trigger these
independently.
So writing functions in
Google Cloud Functions--
well, so for writing
functions, you
can specify a request URL, which
might be something like this,
and provide a body.
So you can just provide
JSON, which could be Grant.
And then the response,
you'll just get 200, OK.
And maybe you'll get a response
body of "Hello, Grant!"
Cloud Function supports
these runtimes, so Node 6, 8,
and 10, Python 3.7, Go 1.11 and
1.12 alpha, as well as Java 8.
Behind the scenes, we have
an HTTP server endpoint.
We provide a fully qualified
domain, an SSL certificate,
autoscaling, as your users
hit your function more often.
And we also integrate
with Stackdriver logging
and Stackdriver error reporting.
You can deploy from
the Cloud Console UI,
or from the command line.
Onto languages and the CLI.
Well, so for Node, a
Google Cloud Function
will look something like this.
It's your typical node where
you can export a variable.
This is just "Hello World."
And we're powering
this through Express 4.
And you can simply
just res.status, 200,
and send the message.
Python is pretty similar.
It uses Flask.
And you can pass the
args, if you want,
and just return a
string, "Hello World".
And for Go, we use the
native HTTP client.
And you can send your
response natively in Go.
You can deploy Google Cloud
Functions from the CLI
and do everything from
calling functions, listing
all your functions, deploying,
deleting, and listing
all the event types.
There's some advanced
options for the CLI
that allows you to specify
different runtimes, different
memory allocations, up to 2
gigabytes, a number of retries,
in case your function fails.
And you can also specify
that this function
will run as a service-account.
Timeouts, environment
variables, triggers, et cetera.
And you can learn more at
cloud.google.com/functions.
Now, I'm really excited
to talk about this part.
This is something
that I've been working
on with [? Slavic ?] and the
Google Cloud Functions team.
This is the Functions Framework.
So what is the
Functions Framework?
Well, it's really a
new underlying backbone
for Google Cloud Functions.
It's an open source project.
It's under github.com/Googl
eCloudPlatform/f
unctions-framework.
And it enables for local
development of your code.
If you're wishing to not
spend 30 to 60 seconds to wait
for your functions
to deploy, you
can simply locally install
the Functions Framework
and have the same
environment that's
used with Google
Cloud Functions,
at least for Node 10 right now.
And we also provide a
transparent [INAUDIBLE]..
And so you can pin your
Functions Framework
on a specific version, so that
you know that your function is
going to run in the
same environment,
even if you G Cloud
Functions [INAUDIBLE]..
Inside the Functions
Framework, what does it do?
Well, so it does a light
transformation of your code.
It first loads the source code.
It creates a light HTTP server--
in this case,
Express 4 for Node.
And it creates a route
for your request.
There's a preset Docker file.
You can see it on
the GitHub repo.
And we spin up
container instances
in response to increased demand.
Cool.
Now I have a couple of demos
that I would love to show you.
So first here, we have our
Google Cloud Platform projects
where I have deployed
a function called BTC.
A simple way to
invoke a function
is just to call the URL.
And here, I actually
have a function deployed
that's calling the Coinbase API
and getting the current bitcoin
price at a certain date.
So in 2017, you could buy a
single bitcoin for $2,100.
See in 2019, it's
increased to $5,400.
Let's go try to run
this locally, though.
So with the new
Functions Framework,
we can simply start the
Functions Framework.
And so this is using
the local NPM package
and just serving
a local host URL.
And I have the query
parameter set up here,
and it's really
exactly the same code.
So you can see in 2016, et
cetera, and the price changes.
We can also, instead of
powering our functions locally,
let's say we want to go and test
against our deployed version.
Well, so rather than
having to go to Chrome,
maybe we want to do
this from the terminal.
We can just use gcloud
and call the function,
and it'll execute and provide
the data right then and there.
Let's say you have
a Google Sheet,
and you want to use Google
Cloud Functions to power
some of the data processing.
Well, I think Google Sheets
is a very flexible UI.
And it's really powerful when
you can combine Google Cloud
Functions and Google Sheets.
So here, I've created a
custom function called BTC_CF.
It takes in a date.
And you can simply
press Enter, and this
will call the Cloud Function,
which we just deployed.
And it'll return the exact
body response from that.
So the powerful part
about Google Sheets
is that you can simply
just drag and drop or click
the bottom right
corner, and you can
see there's all these
prices for all these dates.
And it's powered by
Google Cloud Functions.
So how does this
work, you might ask?
Well, so we can go to Tools
and then Script Editor,
and we have some
lightweight app script code.
Basically, we provide
the date in this format.
And then we do a URL
fetch, which is just
a fetch to this cloud endpoint.
And then we parse with JSON.
And we just want the amount,
and so we just return that.
So that's really cool.
Let's see.
So those are three
different ways
in which you can call your Cloud
Function-- from the command
line, from a browser,
and from Google Sheets.
So in summary, we showed
what functions as a service
is, functions versus
microservices,
writing Google Cloud Functions,
the open source function
framework, and a demo of
three ways in which you
can call Cloud Functions.
You can learn more about
the Functions Framework
at git.io/gcf-ff.
Thank you, so much.
My name is Grant Timmerman.
I would love, if you have
any questions, to tweet at me
@granttimmerman.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]